fasten your seatbelts for this
mind-blowing car company viral video
this clip was a brilliant blend of chaos
beauty and destruction
I love this clip visually absolutely
stunning and I would have loved to be in
that car
this video is gorgeous the colors that
you see in it the green the blue but how
do you make a light splash like paint
scientists what these guys have done is
they have changed all of the lights on
the car and in the room to black lights
now these give off this really slightly
odd purple tinge but they also give off
a lot of lights that we can't see called
ultraviolet lights achieves our fill of
fluorescent paint and the atoms in this
paint are able to absorb the UV light
that's being shone upon them in dimming
so they get really excited but that's
not a really stable place for them to be
so they want to drop back down to a more
relaxed energy level they do this partly
by vibrating and partly by emitting
light at a lower energy and this is the
light that we can see being given off
because it's now low enough energy for
us to detect with our eyes and that's
how you use lights you can't see to make
light you just can't miss unless of
course you're driving a car through it